russian forces are stepping up their
attacks on towns and cities across
ukraine the strikes are hitting military
and civilian targets the assaults come
ahead of a new round of talks between
ukrainian and russian negotiators
expected to start in the next hour or so
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says citizens have no choice but to keep
up their resistance despite the heavy
loss of life
a visit to boost morale ukraine's
president met wounded soldiers
recovering in a kiev military hospital
vladimir zelinski handed out medals in
recognition of their bravery
though russian forces appeared to be
widening their attacks across ukraine
zielenski vowed ultimate victory and he
indicated progress could be made as
bilateral talks continue
representatives of our countries are
holding daily talks via video
our conference has a clear task to do
everything to arrange the meeting of the
presidents
the meeting i'm sure people are waiting
for
obviously this is a difficult story
a hard path
but we need this path
on sunday moscow brought its war nearer
to the polish border
an attack on a military training ground
near lev in western ukraine was the
closest strike so far to nato territory
civilians from all over ukraine have
been fleeing to lev which felt safe
compared to eastern regions under
russian assault
now the city which is listed as a unesco
world heritage site is taking steps to
protect its cultural treasures
in an attempt to offer diversion from
the horrors of war
volunteers have organized tours around
the town for people displaced by the
fighting
i want to distract myself
from war
to think like it's fine but
i know it's not
it's it's
it's not fine right now at heart kharkiv
and i'm i'm really worried for my
friends
and my professors
if i have to judge what is happening now
in ukraine it's comparable to the
destruction of guernica of stalingrad
and with the siege of leningrad
history is repeating itself with all its
nightmares
nightmares that reached the northern
outskirts of the capital kiev on monday
morning
emergency services say a nine-story
apartment building was hit in a russian
artillery strike killing at least two
people
let's cross now to dw's nick connolly
who's standing by in the capital cave
nick new talks scheduled today is there
any reason for ukrainians to be hopeful
i fear not a great deal this is about
the optics about neither side being able
to be seen not to be open to talks
russia wants to somehow slightly reduce
the toxicity of this attack on
ukrainians show that it's open to
diplomacy but if you look at the red
lines at what russia is still trying to
achieve here in ukraine still getting
signals from russia they want ukraine to
abandon ambitions to join nato to
basically give up on its army and be
perpetually vulnerable and open to
russian intervention they want ukraine
to recognize russian ownership of annex
crimea and also to recognize those
self-proclaimed republics in the east
it's very difficult to see how president
zielenski could go back to his people
now after weeks of war and thousands of
dead and you know explain to them why he
is going along with this if ukrainians
already brought such great sacrifices
nick officials where you are in caves
say they're preparing food supplies for
the city's remaining two million
inhabitants in case of a siege what is
the situation where you are
well for now that siege situation we've
been expecting for weeks hasn't happened
yet basically people here in kiev have
been living with kind of news reports
every couple of days saying it's just
another few days until the russians
close that ring around kiev and prevent
food and backup coming in that hasn't
happened so far there is still two major
highways to the southwest and the south
that are open and you can still even
order things online
supplies medicines but even toiletries
other things online they come within a
couple of days from the west of the
country so extraordinary logistics
happening here and no sign of empty
supermarket shelves but yes the
authorities have said that they are
preparing because they do believe the
russians do want to encircle kiev and to
put that pressure on the ukrainian
government so they are prepared for two
weeks should that situation that we've
seen in mario paul repeat itself here in
kiev just on a much bigger scale
on sunday russia attacked a military
target in the far west of the country in
striking distance of nato territory how
significant an attack was that
this was important in two ways this is
about showing ukrainians that there is
no safe hinterland there is nowhere to
go that is not accessible and
destroyable by russian force these
missiles were launched from russian
planes we believe that were flying above
the black sea cruise missiles and about
35 people we now understand lost their
lives they're mainly military people but
this was just a matter of kilometers
away from the border crossings to poland
that have seen hundreds of thousands of
ukrainians queuing for kilometers in
front of those border crossing points
it's a real sense of vulnerability there
but this is also a clear signal to nato
this was a training ground where nato
troops or at least
nato member country troops from america
uk other countries were training
ukrainian forces to use those western
weapons that have proved so successful
for the ukrainians in recent weeks
so that training ground as kind of proxy
for western support for ukraine we've
heard vladimir putin recent days saying
if more significant weaponry comes in
from the west then
russia will attack those shipments those
supplies and basically we'll see any
country
aiming to help ukraine as a party to
this conflict so a very clear attempt to
try and
scare off western support for ukraine um
and a sense here that yeah this is now a
country that is a war along its
basically three thousand kilometer
border with russia and belarus
now places in the south that are now
under russian control such as the city
of herson we're seeing people fighting
back what's the situation there in those
occupied towns
we've seen some extraordinary images on
social media of people going out to
protest in spite of russian military
control of those cities in spite of
attempts to create kind of proxy states
in the country of the kind we saw in
donetsk and back in 2014 um ukrainian
politicians the local politicians not
going along with it the attempt to
create a so-called herzon people's
republic that we saw over the weekend
failing because basically the elected
ukrainian officials just wouldn't go
along with it despite a lot of pressure
being applied to them ordinary people
getting out of the streets with
ukrainian flags in some cases clambering
on russian tanks with ukrainian flags
and telling those russian soldiers to go
home we've seen the russian authorities
getting progressively more aggressive
towards those protesters firing to the
air we've heard of arrests a ukrainian
mayor institu melatuple was kidnapped by
the russian forces and they've put now
their own proxy person in charge but
definitely i think a lot more in the way
of resistance and willingness to take
risks from the ordinary kind of
residential population of those cities
than the russians certainly bargained
for well nick thank you very much for
that update dw's nick connolly in kiev
here are some other developments in the
conflict now authorities in ukraine's
besieged port city of mariupol say the
city is running out of its last reserves
of food and water they also accuse
russian forces of continuing to shell
non-military targets ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky is urging the russian
military to allow a convoy with medical
aid and food into the city
police across russia have arrested more
than 800 people for protesting the
invasion moscow authorities say they
detained 300 people for breaching public
order police also arrested dozens in
saint petersburg as well as 30 other
cities
internet traffic monitors say the social
media platform instagram has been
restricted across russia state
regulators blocked the platform after
its owner meta said it would allow users
in ukraine to call for violence against
russian soldiers moscow had already
blocked facebook also owned by metta
a u.s journalist has been killed while
reporting near kiev brent renault was
traveling to film refugees fleeing the
town of urpin when his vehicle came
under fire another journalist was
wounded in the attack which ukraine
blames on russian
forces this footage shows the moments
after two journalists were shot in
erpine
juan arredondo was wounded and brought
to a hospital where he recounted what
had happened
we crossed one the first bridge in
europe
we're going to film other refugees
leaving
and we got into a car somebody offered
to take us to the other bridge
and we crossed the checkpoint and they
start shooting at us so the driver
turned around and they kept shooting
it's two of us my friend's friend
renault
and he's been shot and left behind
[Music]
arredondo didn't yet know that renault a
50-year-old award-winning documentary
filmmaker had died at the scene
ukrainian officials blamed russian
forces for the shooting
several media crews have come under fire
since russia's invasion of ukraine
renault is believed to be the first
foreign journalist to be killed
eopin a suburb about 20 kilometers
outside kiev has been under heavy
bombardment as russian armoured vehicles
advance towards ukraine's capital
thousands of people are fleeing in
dangerous conditions
some evacuees have come under fire but
staying is also terrifying
our building was hit with a missile and
two apartments next to ours were just
smashed
we've got cases of looting it's just
horrible very very horrible
all the windows were broken and the
balcony fell down
and the tenth floor above us was just
dust
my daughter came and said mama take your
stuff until this i didn't want to leave
my town
the refugees hoped to find relative
safety away from their hometown
rendered uninhabitable by the fighting